Financials are looking great.
Paul, do you have any comments on staffing?
I was thinking about that because we get a few more contractor types in...
Hold on, I'm sorry.
Rex!
Get down!
Well, to me, staffing is a huge impact.
Is that me?
That's not me at all.
I just want to go over a couple of details as we move into our next section here.
We got three new departments coming on...
Breaking up a little bit, guys.
Driving through a dead spot.
Sorry, guys.
That's it, guys.
Beth, you'll send out a recap email...
...that could've basically taken the place of this whole meeting, correct?
Yup, always do.
Yeah thanks for doing that, Beth.
Dave!
You've been here the whole time?
Yeah.
Well, thanks everyone once again.
Oh, one more...